Speaker 1: Electric vehicles are increasingly
a target of the anti-everything right wing. As
many of you know, I am for electric vehicles. I
have an electric vehicle. I think they're great.
In many ways. Nothing is perfect. Everything
has pros and cons. I think that the reality
of electric vehicles is good enough. I don't feel
like anything needs to be exaggerated about them.
But also a lot of the claims made about electric
vehicles that are negative claims are false. And
I'm going to play for you such an example on
Fox News yesterday, Judge Jeanine Pirro. This
is an image of her, although Rivera but he's on
a program with Judge Jeanine Pirro. She delivered
an unhinged tirade about electric vehicles that
ends up with her yelling, what if you live in
middle America? Who gives a damn about what's
happening in New York City? I mean, completely
unintelligible. Listen to the specific claims
she makes and we'll talk about them one by one.
Speaker 2: I submit respectfully that if they want
to lead by example, then they've got to bite the
bullet. Okay. This is what I think I was doing
when Joe Biden came out and he told those mom
and pop gas stations to lower their prices and do
it. Now, they all got scared of Joe and they said
we better lower the price of gas. Look, that's
all hogwash. What this guy is doing right now is
he's taking credit for something that he didn't
do. Okay. And now if he declares this emergency,
he's going to everybody's going to say,
oh, my gosh, what are we going to do?
There's not going to be any gas. And even
though he's taking credit for more gas,
they've got to buy now an electric vehicle. Okay.
Speaker 1: So so before she even gets into
electric vehicles, this is the same old story.
Biden gets all of the blame for the run up of
gas prices and none of the credit for the
decline. Now, I think he has barely anything
to do with both. And I said that under Trump, I
said it under Obama. Now I said it under Bush.
Presidents have very little to do with gas prices,
but on Fox, they blame Biden for the increase and
they don't give him credit. But then now she
says, really, the switcheroo is they want to
get you on electric vehicles, an electric vehicle.
Speaker 2: The average woman costs $64,000. The
average car costs $46,000. The average American
doesn't have a new car. So the average American
and would Pete Boot, a judge says, look, you
may pay a little more in your car payment. The
average American doesn't have a car payment.
Speaker 1: Okay. So first of all. Wow. If you
were to even start, if Americans don't have car
payments, then it's not really even relevant.
But the important thing here is when she talks
about the average price of electric vehicles,
the number she states is outdated. Actually
average price of electric vehicle 2022,
it's down to $54,000. So let's actually think that
through. Jeanine says nobody can afford electric
vehicles. Average electric vehicle costs 64 K and
average non electric vehicle new costs 46 K. Okay,
that's a difference of $18,000. The real
average price of an electric vehicle in 2022 is
$54,000. Now, it's still more, right? 54,000
versus 46,000, but there's a 70 up to a 70 $500
federal credit for people who buy
electric vehicles. So all of a sudden,
your $8,000 difference becomes much smaller. And
then you have the fact that on average, it costs
one third of what it costs in a gas vehicle to
go one mile with an electric vehicle. So Janine's
just wrong. The cars aren't cheap for sure. But
when you consider the gas savings and the credit,
it's actually not as big of a difference
anymore. Now, not everybody gets new
cars. That's absolutely true. Let's continue.
Speaker 2: The average American is driving a car
that he or she has had for a long time.
And they're not making payments. The car
is paid for. It's old. They're just surviving and
deciding if they have enough gas to go to work and
to buy the food that they need. And the sad part
of all this is that they don't understand America.
They don't understand what's going on in America
when they say, oh, just fine electric vehicle
or oh, the government should should get
electric vehicles, but we don't have the
infrastructure for electric vehicles. We can.
Speaker 1: In part because the government has
not invested enough in that infrastructure.
Right. I mean, the infrastructure will follow
demand. We are already seeing that in areas
where you see more electrical vehicle sales,
you see more companies enter the market and
say, we're going to do charging stations,
we're going do portable charging, we're going
to do a device that you can keep in your trunk
with a fully charged battery to charge right
out of it. And then you just swing by and you
get one that's already charged and leave
yours. All of these things are they talk
about the market, allow the market to function.
Speaker 2: I'm not going to tell you who it is,
but the guy that I buy some of my cars from,
he says to me, Janine, I'm buying one. He said,
I don't even like it. I don't want to drive
it. I can't drive it anywhere but around town.
This is all. Let me finish. This is all
make believe nonsense where America is
not supporting these green lunatics. I was
driving to work today, went to Starbucks
charging and charging stations in the Starbucks.
Speaker 1: Yeah, right.
Speaker 2: Right. It's growing. The infrastructure
will. What if you're an American living in middle
America gives a damn about what's going
on in New York City next to the Starbucks?
Speaker 1: You know, the other thing that they
often will talk about with middle America is
there's no infrastructure. You don't have
places to charge. Most people don't need to
charge anywhere other than home. This is
the other the the anti electric vehicle.
I don't want to call it an industry. The opponents
of electric vehicles will often say these vehicles
just don't have long enough ranges where you
can count on going and coming back from work,
even in many cases, even in middle America. That's
an even bigger issue. This is completely untrue.
The median electric vehicle has gone from being
able to drive 68 miles without a charge in 2011
to 234 miles right now. That's the median vehicle.
And there's ones with much longer ranges. Very
few people, even in middle America, have a commute
that would make that median range a problem. Let's
be conservative. Your goal is I want to go to work
and back and I don't want to be cutting it close.
I want 20% battery remaining when I get home
with the median electric vehicle, 234 mile range,
you can do a 94 mile commute. Now, I don't mean
94 miles roundtrip. I mean you can go 94 miles to
work, come back 94 miles and still have 20%
battery left over. You get the gas savings,
you can get the federal credit for the vehicle
and you don't have to charge anywhere but at home.
In addition to that, many electric companies now
give you rebates if you charge during off peak
hours. I just set up my vehicle now by charging
after I think it's 9 p.m. by charging only after
9 p.m. I get something like, you know, $0.05 per
kilowatt hour back and I get a check every month
it. They are lying. Okay. These are these are
simply not issues. The cost of the vehicles.
Sure. It's coming down the range of the vehicles.
It's increasing the cost of the electricity. It's
a fraction of what gas cost. And of course,
we could have instead of subsidized gasoline,
we could get rid of those subsidies, let the
cost of gas really reflect the total cost,
including the environmental cost, which
we don't we don't have accurate gas prices
in the United States and further
subsidize the electric vehicles. So
Jeanine is completely unhinged, attacking
everything that is good. If Jeanine is
against it, you should consider whether
it's something we should be very happy about